la sauce pour barbecue lone star le
partenaire idéal de votre poulet tu peux
en faire une autre idole est la sauce
pour barbecue lone star on propose pas
et roland quelque chose oui script pas
pour le moment n'a pas vraiment l'air
dans son assiette
est-ce que ça va rouler mal on sait
quelque chose
[Musique]
tu as vu lui si dernièrement
ce fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu ma
fille appelle là
il faut que je te dise quelque chose
papa qu'est ce que tu fais ici je me
suis longtemps si tu as eu envie de
parler avec moi c'est juste parce que tu
veux qu'on se réconcilie avant de mourir
le mot la chance de finir ma vie sur une
bonne note
et j'entendais parler d'une asso ce qui
s'appelle acquise de la promotion et la
préservation des westerns ils veulent
que décerner un prix
y'a qu'un film dont je suis vraiment
fier et c'était il ya quarante ans
les charlotte charlotte lui
celui
est ce que tu es marié divorcé
c'est toi qui m'a invité je trouve ça un
peu bizarre tu as quel âge emplettes et
toi tu as quel âge 60
des anges
d'une certaine façon je restais mort
pendant longtemps
dix ans je suis revenu à l'egypte
franchement les mecs jeunes comme vous
là c'est terminé les hommes âgés sont
extraordinaires
l'histoire j'ai reçu des offres des
script vasif fax paul texte tu te sers
encore d'un vase
[Musique]
monsieur l'ihedn
je suis rien sans chacun de vous
[Musique]